what a Smosh mean so much to you like
we're like really sad they're the only
ones who can actually pick you up
I
alright
ready
which one's been craving this crazy
crazy the non-stop train of craziness I
want to say that it's a crazy train yes
honestly we boys coming we went from
rehearsal at seven forty-five am too
going back to our room to change into
our clothes for our main stage
performance then after the main stage
performance we had a run over to our
signing and after that we had to go
immediately to film lunchtime
you know just watching someone to work
it makes you want it to work really bad
go ahead just work so we're the guys my
toy do its work deserve it ready got
that yes there okay
you
food battle is sort of we've always
wanted to create a game that sort of
centered around this this fictional game
that Anthony played in a food battle
years ago 2009 and we never we never
really knew how we were going to do it
and then but in the discussion yeah the
discussion of IndieGoGo came up and
we're like okay so maybe that we can
actually make this work and then with
the help of our viewers you know giving
us their input on what they want to see
and just getting people excited about
about the project it's it's really been
an experience we've never done anything
like this so it's sort of a learning
experience you know but it's fun
I heard that the tickets were sold out I
was so depressed and everything and all
of a sudden his food battle game showing
up and it was very a big surprise when I
got two thousand dollars the perk is
just amazing Oh perfect high school prom
pose good this is most of this is high
school bro the way you have faced the
other way let's see the real problem
faces right now go for the hook there it
is the three way from let's go can you
jump okay 120 you're really why are you
that's a good cause let's get buzzed
that looks sexy everybody
it was like a once-in-a-lifetime thing
that she really wanted to do which is
it's crazy really yeah she was she was
super stoked we yeah we sit we just did
the most random poses up there it was it
got a little weird yeah but it was fun
it was fine one yeah and she I think she
had a lot of fun perfect like everything
beyond really happened and wasn't
worthless definitely you know that
that's the cool thing about IndieGoGo
it's not like we're forcing people to
give us money right where we're giving
them something that they want right and
and that's the cool sort of trade off is
that we're able to create something that
they will hopefully enjoy and I'm pretty
sure they will because this game is
gonna kick ass and it's gonna be free
sometimes yeah yeah yeah they said like
I got two hundred dollars worth of
merchandise and I just take it out what
I wanted and I got the best photos in
the world that it's gonna be emailed to
my mom said so
right thank you
this week has been like the craziest
week ever i don't think i have had a
moment without a headache yeah it's a
good headache yeah it's a good at yeah
it's like okay we gotta you know do the
game the magazine and yeah i mean we're
doing a lot of stuff they don't have to
do what we think everyone will really
like so we're just pushing ourselves to
do as much as you can hello Carly Sophie
k Tiffany Julia and Audrey Barbara but
you were here you should've been there
maybe we wouldn't be talking this way
yes why are we going anyway I don't know
Christophe
it's so crazy with with VidCon because
you think that you know it's just just
some people probably from around the
area that are coming but we were meeting
people that that came from Australia
from Spain Denmark people have been like
they're like oh I flew 12 hours and one
of the only people I wanted me with you
guys and that's the weird sort of thing
about about VidCon you know is that
there's these people that are
dispassionate about about the space and
it's something that you know you might
you might see in something bigger like
comic-con no but now it's happening in
our space which is pretty crazy